herzlich willkommen zu meinen heutigen
video leute ihr seht herzlich willkommen
zu machen heutige video leute wir kochen
heute ein menü aus den schlechtesten
rezepten die das internet zu bieten hat
es gibt auch tumblr einen block des
worst of chefkoch also chef kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch die seite
wo menschen rezepte fördern die kölner
gibt es ziemlich gute sachen aber auch
ziemlich eigenartige sachen und aus
diesen sachen habe ich mir ein kleines
einfaches menü zusammengestellt und wir
kochen das wollte einfach mein vater
könnte erforscht bei sich bleibt euch
hierbei eine salami chips aus dem ofen
warum welcher mensch überlegt sich das
schreibt ein rezept darüber und
veröffentlicht das im internet das in
sachen brauchen kein rezept so länder
haben ist das rezept quasi salami chefs
aus dem ofen den obstsalat links in den
ofen
sie wird nichts bringen aber lesen jetzt
als rezept natürlich erstmalig ein
schwede kommt euch mal an was da für ein
rezept steht für salami chips
arbeitszeit ca 10 minuten geschafft in
einem vakuum auf zirka 100 abschlag vor
als eine wirklich schon gemacht
ein backblech mit backpapier vorbereitet
ist auch schon drin die pelle von salami
den fernseher wie schneiden wir haben
einfach geschnitten gekauft so kann man
noch wichtige minuten sparen bei diesem
sehr zeitaufwändigen rezept durch die
verwendung von gewürzen wie zum beispiel
salz pfeffer paprika knoblauch kann
etwas mehr pfiff auf dieser lage chips
bringen
ist ja auch egal was sonst auch hier
steht ich würde sagen wir wohl nicht nur
die salami also ja mir hähnchen salami
einfach in scheiben gekauft wie gesagt
um zeit zu sparen
in den rezensionen steht so hier steht
wir haben das rezept in unserer wg
ausprobiert ein muss für jede party
das kann ich glaube ich so bestätigen
gucken wir natürlich erst mal da
empfiehlt ein kommentarschreiber dass
man den ganzen noch cent hinzu führt er
war das ganze eine interessante süßes
gibt ist glaube ich nicht und ich glaube
auch nicht dass dieser kommentar ist
gemeint ist alles in einem unter schönes
prozent dass man nur weiter empfehlen
kann ich bin mal gespannt irgendwie
wirkt es nicht so ganz überzeugend auf
mich also ja wir nehmen jetzt erstmal
eine schadet und ein bisschen ruhe rein
und dann ein paar gewürze wird sagen wir
tun jetzt hier mal ein bisschen öl rein
wir müssen ja auch nicht so viele salami
chips machen sie werden wahrscheinlich
so lecker dass man gar nicht alle essen
kann ein wenig patrick ein wenig chemie
ein bisschen hab vorüber und helfer
natürlich und ein bisschen curry noch
zum schluss vielleicht wenn ihr jetzt
tun wir noch zählt dazu aber nur wenn
ihr jetzt auch nur noch einmal sowie
verrühren das ganze jetzt mal ich zeig
euch das wissen ganz genau weil ich
glaube es ist relativ schwer dass wir
das alleine
aber dafür bin ich ja auch da irgendwie
mal die salami ich bin echt gesagt
überhaupt kein freund von salami aber
das rezept kleiner papier gut dass frau
studieren musste also nehme hier eine
scheibe salami packen die in unsere
gewürz und legen die erstmal hier ab
zuerst wiederholt den vorgang ein paar
mal ich weiß was ich tue freundin
deshalb sage ich ganz unbesorgt wir
machen einfach mal dass einer mal 3 sei
es ein guter koch war es natürlich seine
sicherheitsvorkehrungen zu treffen ja
komm ran freunde ja komplett an die
schönheit da einfach vorsichtig wurzel
stelle einen timer auf 15 minuten
okay der parador freunde also machen wir
mit dem hauptgericht weiter das habe ich
natürlich nicht mindert den cs ich habe
mir dann nämlich dass überbackene
catcher bot herausgesucht lasst euch ja
noch mal auf der zunge zergehen nahm und
diesen dem überbackenes ketchup droht
schon wieder klassischer fall von ersten
das ist kein rezept und zweitens das ist
einfach unmenschlich auch dieses foto
dazu also absolute hammer
beschreibung einfach und super lecker da
bin ich mir sicher die zutaten und 14
scheiben brot ps entscheiden käse wir
machen das auch wieder in der
abgespeckten form bereit und wenn durch
ein backofen auf 180 grad an ober
unterhitze vorheizen ein blech mit
backpapier auslegen die brotscheiben
darauf verteilen und dünnen mit ketchup
bestreiten den käse auflegen 10 bis 15
minuten überbacken euro freunde kommen
wir kurz fiel aber vorbereiten aber da
drin
das wird herrlich ohne dass er die
christliche salami trip wir brauchen
hier
käse käse und brot ich mache hier die
kindes variante und nehmen dafür
weissbrodt glaub das ist ein gericht was
vor allem sehr ernährungsbewusste leute
machen und dann darf ich mir macht
wahrscheinlich sind wenn man dann
irgendwie noch so ein bisschen die
komponente rein packt so dundee und
sketche und das versprechen wir jetzt
dünn auf dem brot es muss ja gesund
bleiben so muss das seien ungefähr
aussehen wenn ihr das jetzt dann gleich
nach dem video zu hause nach macht und
fertig ist das hauptgericht hast du dich
jetzt auch sofort in den open doch das 4
alexa kaymer auf 15 minuten 15 minuten
da kommen wir so schwer es ist mal
wieder eine köstlichkeit die
ihresgleichen sucht wir haben hier den
apfel bürger beschreibung der gesunde
und kalorienarme bürger mit diesem
wirklich traumhaften foto 4 apple zwei
bis acht reiswaffeln sehr überschaubare
zutaten zubereiten apple in scheiben
schneiden und kiwis in scheiben
schneiden und 30 öffnen dazwischen
machen und das dann auf spießen
es geht mir wirklich nicht in den kopf
warum menschen sich hinsetzen das
aufschreiben und das alles gericht
bezieht in zwölf wochen macht man die
person kleiner fan trägt die den apfel
bürger erstellt hatte übrigens 13 1615
rezepte auf chef huber stellt das
erklärt dann auch wie man auf den apfel
bürger kommen aber wir fangen mit der
zubereitung sofort ist der apfel war ja
so scheinen haben deshalb würde ich
sagen schneiden immer oben und unten ab
wir wahrscheinlich wird stefan f
und es macht dann hat man es einfach
nicht so perfekt der bitte jetzt braune
verdammt also war ich nicht nachgedacht
so jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch den
strunk entfernen das macht man in der
regel so ich weiß was ich mache ich es
jeden tag ab egal warum nicht er aber
natürlich schade aber es geht doch so
viel schneller ich habe jetzt einfach
mal die sachen hier vorbereitet jetzt
schnappe ich mir noch die rafi fertig in
zwei minuten sind auf dieser limitierten
dass sie danach köstlicher heute nicht
wirklich knapp
und dafür brauchen wir jetzt erstmal die
reise warten die müssen wir natürlich
auf die richtige spur zu bringen weil
das ist ja auch was fürs auge westlicher
bürger schnappen wir uns hier natürlich
dass unsere brot- kiwi eine kiwi scheibe
noch 1 8 für ring noch eine kniescheibe
und dann kommt auch schon der bürger
deckel drauf und jetzt müssen wir das
ganze natürlich noch stabilisieren mit
einem zahnstocher sieht es nicht
köstliche aus so leute den finals
abgelaufenen unsere salami chips sind
fertig die wollen jetzt erstmal aus dem
ofen weiter obenauf dann beziehen wir
uns das hier ganz kurz vor und darunter
auch köstlich aus guckt man hier vorne
leute kriegt man schon einen blick auf
die köstlichen capture boote wenig
plaziert es dieser lage chats und
richten die schon mal schön auf unserem
teller kennt hier anerkennt was
vielleicht wir machen das jetzt mal hier
sowie in der sterneküche und packen wir
noch so ein bisschen bei sami vornehmen
da sieht es noch noch schöner aus also
vorspeise steht nachspeise steht und wer
hätte auch unsere köstliche hauptspeise
warten müssen wir natürlich auch was
trinken afrika pier 330 liter bier ein
halber teelöffel paprikapulver edelsüß
zu bereiten dafür untersucht haben bei
crêpes und vermischen teppich das kriege
ich hin
dann können wir auch gleich essen die
habe ich mal eine flasche alkohol greift
wir dann trinkt man natürlich nur
alkoholfrei wenn man ein vorbild ist das
schenken wir es hier mal vorsichtig ein
[Applaus]
das schmeckt jetzt ganz wichtig der
heide teelöffel paprika zahlen das ist
etwa ein halber teelöffel den markt rein
alexa wendet sich auch zu wort stoppt
dann ist auch die hauptspeise fertig
hier tropft jetzt langsam
das ist rechtlich schwieriger ich heute
den ofen aus jetzt auch überhaupt kein
stuhl mehr drin wenn es einmal blöd ist
und so schmeckt wie kann ich erweise am
allerbesten ich würde sagen bevor
gegessen wird einfach jetzt immer ein
paar von diesem wunderschönen essen
[Musik]
da ist es also unser essen wer mitessen
wir beginnen die mahlzeit mit einem
großen salami chip mit minimaler auch
die verlegung in die höhe bekommen zu
verlegen aber nicht jetzt muss nicht
richtiger also schnappen sondern setzen
also unser land kipp bestimmt ist
geschichte
was ist das ich hab keine video fertig
gemacht freute sich der coach über ehre
dass ich mir dafür sich nur wenige was
anschlüssen sowie zwei bretter
aneinander
magnifique der wende nicht nutzen müssen
sie spricht von falschen denkens aber
sowas 15 sebastian könnte so womöglich
kommt und lustigerweise ist paprika wir
der perfekte begleiter für jeden gang
also für jedes gerät das er jetzt mal
ein stück davon sehr gut
das protein gerecht für fitness bewusst
mit ok na gut dann schnappt ihm einst
von den brötchen etwa kosten würde
aber ich scheine ja das dampft richtig
hätte überbackene capture brot
herunterzieht sie jetzt meiner review
ja was soll ich sagen
also schmeckt wie man es erwarten würde
das ist das signal dass mehr menschen
dafür den backofen an machen so gut zu
machen das ist jetzt nicht egl erregend
aber es ist doch auch beheben
du denkst es wirklich ich würde das
nicht ausschließen dass ich habe sowas
angesprochen meinte er kocht er
eigentlich nie so richtig doch toast mit
schicken
ich bin perfekt gleitet dann haben wir
schon mal ein befürworter von meinen
kochkünsten gefunden
ich würde sagen lasst gerne ein like das
war relativ aufwendig das ganze zu
kochen einkaufen nein hat es nicht passt
trotzdem leider
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video machst
du jeden tag auf die überkaufte video
wir sehen uns